Remember that membership is our primary funding
source.
I invite you to grab a membership and join
Pacman dot com.
You can use the coupon code 20-20 now all
one word, all lowercase two zero two zero
A.W. to save 66 percent.
If you could imagine, that is a discount that
is certainly immoral and sometimes illegal
depending where you live.
It's too big of a discount.
Grab a membership at join Pacman dot com.
I was browsing the David Pakman show sub Reddit
this morning at David Pakman dot com slash.
Read it.
That's our EDI's DHT.
And I saw a post called What the Hell is Wrong
With You Americans?
Which says, I mean, seriously, last night's
debates wouldn't even be normal in Turkmenistan.
That's an insult to the Turk Menees.
What the hell happened to you people?
You used to be the amazing people.
Now you were looking at two geriatric rapists,
snarling half finished sentences and blatant
lies to each other.
What the hell happened?
I reject the characterization of two geriatric
rapists.
It seems like maybe you've fallen for some
an unconfirmed conspiracy theories there or
whatever the case may be.
But dozens of e-mails like that coming in
from all over the world.
What is wrong with you people?
Even if Trump loses, as I've been saying,
how are 60 million of you voting for this
guy?
And this is a reality.
We have to contend with the world.
At one point, maybe they were laughing.
They're shocked.
The rest of the world is disgusted.
The rest of the world's pities us.
The rest of the world is concerned because
we have more than 60 million people here who
not only voted for Trump, but they're going
to do it again.
Another user on the sub Reddit nerd Linger
says, Is anybody else not even surprised that
people are defending Trump's performance yesterday,
blaming Chris Wallace, accusing Biden of having
an earpiece playing the both sides game as
if both candidates were completely unhinged
last night.
Acting offended over Biden calling Trump a
clown.
Proud boys aren't white nationalists.
I figured this would happen if Trump gave
the most indefensible appearance possible.
And he did.
And I'm not at all surprised, really.
I feel so desensitized to this stuff.
Now, David really needs to do a good, long
episode on long term implications of Trump
ism.
Yeah, I mean, we knew.
Listen, every debate, every year, every election
cycle, each side claims they won.
Trump claims he won.
Biden claims he won.
In reality, what really matters is how the
the relatively few and far between undecided
voters see it, because Trump's base is already
voting for Trump.
The anti Trump people are already voting for
Joe Biden.
So it's not really surprising that the Trump
base is defending Trump's performance.
But you are right about the unfortunate reality.
As I said, just because of the last Reddit
post.
Even if Trump loses, what happens with Trump
ism?
And I think that there is a real risk that
if Donald Trump gets reelected, it's not just
four more years of Trump.
It bolsters the possibility of one of the
Trump children running in 2024 and things
get even uglier.
If you can imagine that last notable post
from the subhead, it from user genius of Slaughter,
who says Trump saying he would run the country
like his business is the only true thing he's
ever said.
Look at Trump's tax returns, man.
So inspirational yet.
Can.
Can we put to bed this idea that we need a
businessperson president?
This is something that we heard when Mitt
Romney was running in 2012.
And at the time, the question was, what example
do we have of a businessman turned president
that did really well?
And there there were no examples.
We now have a supposed businessman turned
president, and it's been an unmitigated and
total disaster.
So.
So we.
We need to stop with that.
And in fact, I would love to see presidents
come from other backgrounds altogether.
What about a scientist president?
What about a president with a background in
education or philosophy as an example?
Or maybe even economics?
I know, you know, some some maybe wouldn't
like that, but we we actually have a problem
where the scope of where presidents come from
is too narrow.
And and I think we would be far, far better
served to expand that in other directions
than businessman president.
Join the discussion at David Pakman dot com
slash.
Read it